ثمن الحرب الحقيقيه
واذا كان الجيش المصري قدر يعملها مره فهو
هيبقى قدر يعملها كل مره كل مره
ليست الحادثه الاولى ولن تكون الاخيره في
الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه نعم رصاصات
متسكعه يطلقها جندي مصري تهز اركانه تل
ابيب جنرال اسرائيلي يعلنها ما حدث في
اسرائيل اليوم صعب جدا هو اخر يهدد مصر
صراحه التحقيق مع المصريين سيكون حادا ولن
نسامح ثلاثه قتلى منهم اسرائيليان وعلى
راسهم هذه المجنده وضابط اسرائيلي في حاله
حرجه يا الهي يفاجعه المصريه هزت ارجاء
اسرائيل لتنفض الغبار عن اتفاقيه السلام
الدوليه بين اسرائيل ومصر كيف علق جنرالات
الجيش الاسرائيلي على الحادث وماذا قال
نتنياهو عن مستقبل العلاقات مع مصر وهل
ستقوم اسرائيل بشتم ورقه السلام التي
وقعتها مع مصر لتعرف كل تلك الاسئله تابع
الفيديو للنهايه
فاجعه مصريه كل شيء كان هادئا تماما في
التاسعه ليلا جندي ومجنده اسرائيليان
يستلمان مهمتهما في برج المراقبه على بعد
ثلاثه كيلومترات من معبر العوجه بالقرب من
الحدود المصريه الثالثه والنصف صباحا يعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قام باحباط محاوله
لتعريب المخدرات الهدوء يعود من جديد ولكن
تاتي السادسه صباحا بمفاجاه لم تكن في
الحسبان الجندي والمجنده يبلغان قيادتهما
لانهما سمع دوي اطلاق نيران في المنطقه
وانهما سينزلان لاستكشاف الامر تمر ساعات
والاتصال ينقطع تماما بين القياده
الاسرائيليه والجنديين القياده تذهب لتبحث
عن الجنديين لتاتي التاسعه صباحا
صدمه الكبرى القوات الاسرائيليه تجد جثتي
الجندي والمجنده ملقيتين على الارض
سريعتين بالرصاص القلق يعم ارجاء المكان
والقوات الاسرائيليه تقوم بعمليات تمشيط
واسعه جدا وتعززها بالمروحيات المقاتله
الثانيه عشره ظهرا الجيش الاسرائيلي يعترف
بمقتل جندي ومجنده بالرصاص وبعدها بقليل
يعلن سقوط القتيل الثالث واصابه ضابط
اسرائيلي يا الهي ما الذي يحدث جندي مصري
بمفرده يتسبب بكل هذه المجزره ليتم
التعزيز جوا وبرا من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه وياتي بعدها خبر الجندي
المصري وهو يرتدي زي الشرطه المصريه يعانق
بندقيته رافضا تركها الشرطه الاسرائيليه
تعلن اغلقنا كل الطرق والمحاور التي تؤدي
الى الحدود مع الجيش المصري يولين فجر
اليوم السبت قام احد عناصر الامن المكلفه
بتامين خط الحدود الدوليه بمطارده عناصر
تهريب المخدرات واثناء المطارده قام فرد
الامن باختراق حاجز التامين وتبادل اطلاق
النيران مما ادى الى وفاه ثلاثه من عناصر
التامين الاسرائيليين واصابه اثنين اخرين
بالاضافه الى وفاه فرد التامين المصري
اثناء تبادل اطلاق النيران رئيس الاركان
بالجيش الاسرائيلي اللواء هرتهاليفي مجرى
اليوم حادث صعب جدا سقط خلاله جنديان
ومجنده من خيره ابناءنا في نشاط عمليتي
للحفاظ على امن الحدود مع مصر واللواء
لعازرته لدانو يهدد مصر قائلا ان كل
الاتجاهات قيد الفحص والتحقيق مع المصريين
سيكون حادا يا الهي ماذا حدث هل قتل
الجنود الاسرائيليون الثلاثه على يد
الجندي المصري وحده فعلا امنا هناك افرادا
اخرين اشتركوا معه ولماذا حادث عابر ام
خطا مقصود معروف ان السياج الموجود على
الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه من الصعب جدا
اختراقه فهو مزود باحدث التقنيات فضلا عن
طريقه بناءه وارتفاعه وحتى اذا استطاع
مهربو المخدرات اختراقه فذلك يحدث
باستعمال سلالم عاليه وادوات معينه فكيف
يخترقه الجندي المصري وحده تكهنات عديده
غير رسميه تقول ان الجندي المصري استغلت
ظروف احباط عمليه التهريب التي حدثت فجرا
واغتسلل عبر الحدود وقتل الجنديين
والمجنده الاسرائيليه ثم نصب كمينا ليوقع
بالقتيل الثالث فان الحادثه مقصوده ومخطط
لها مسبقا ولكن هذا الراي يفتقر الى دليل
قاطع خصوصا مع احتمال وجود محاوله لتهريب
المخدرات عند نفس المنطقه داخل الحدود
المصريه ومن الطبيعي ان يتبعهم الامن
المصري كما قال الجيش المصري في بيانه
ولكن السؤال الاهم الان هل ستؤثر تلك
الحادثه على اتفاقيه السلام بين مصر
واسرائيل وستكون هي شراره حرب بينهما
ستشهدها الايام المقبله خصوصا مع تصريحات
بعض ادويه الجيش الاسرائيلي الحاده لا احد
يريد الحرب
تصريحات بعض الويه الجيش الاسرائيلي والتي
ربما ترقى لان توصف بالتهديدات جاءت
تصريحات اخرى وعلى مستويات اكبر وكانها
تقول مهلا مهلا فلا احد يريد الحرب وراس
السلطه في اسرائيل بنيامين تنياهو اعلنها
صراحه لوزراء حكومته الحادث الامني الذي
حدث على الحدود مع مصر هو حادث عابر ولم
يؤثر على التعاون المشترك الذي يشمل حفظ
الامن بين البلدين ووزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يطلب من نظيره المصري الاجتماع
من اجل التعاون على تجاوز تلك الحادثه في
حين اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان عمليات
التمشيط لا زالت مستمره وتتم بالتنسيق مع
الجيش المصري وان هناك نوعا من التعاون
بين الجانبين من اجل عبور تلك الحادثه
الاستثنائيه لا شك في ان ما حدث اليوم كان
صعبا ومرا على اسرائيل ولكن اسرائيل ومصر
تعريفين جيدا مراره الحروب ما يعني ان
تقطيع ورقه السلام بينهما لن يكون سهلا
وجعله شاهدا لك
[موسيقى]
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
محمد رسول الله قال
محمد
[موسيقى]